auf das zu anfang eine prinzessin seine
große schwester und französischer
supertolle ausrichten darf hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe euch ja schon länger versprochen
dass ich mal ein video über meine
schwangerschaft mache und euch mal auf
den neuesten stand bringen
ich meine dass ich schwanger bin wissen
ja die meisten schon ich werde auch
immer runder
also die schürze wölbt sich von mal zu
mal immer mehr nach vorne und ja heute
ist es soweit ich habe ein paar fragen
von euch gesammelt und hab mir gedacht
ich erzähle ist einfach drauflos also
aktuell wenig grad in der 21
schwangerschaftswoche eine
schwangerschaft 40 wochen
und deswegen habe ich echt schon die
hälfte hinter mir ich kann es selber
kaum glauben weil im prinzip haben wir
selbst erst vor kurzem erfahren und
jetzt sind wir doch schon wieder soweit
und noch mal 20 euro 19 bereich dann
habe ich ja schon alles geschafft und
hat mich schon baby dass es an mir das
geschwisterchen
ich weiß nicht was ihr alles so wissen
wollte deswegen hatte ich ja diese
fragen gesammelt und fangen jetzt
einfach mal an
also wir morath und ich wir wissen schon
seit dem 14
vor dass ich schwanger bin da habe ich
nämlich den test gemacht und praktisch
an bord am valentinstag damit überrascht
denn ich hatte wie letztes und falls ja
schon kein valentinstags geschenk für
ihn und hab ich mir das eben ein
gefallen und wir kommen heute macht den
test heute überrascht zu ihm
und dann waren wirklich zum glück auch
positiv und das war dann praktisch
meinen valentinstags geschenk an ihn
ganz witzig fand sich dabei an dem tag
war auch der letzte tag auf der ambiente
das heißt wir sind an dem tag noch mal
auf die ambiente messe gefahren und ich
weiß nicht wie aber irgendwie habt ihr
dann alle direkt nach diesem video dann
auch gefragt ob ich schwanger bin obwohl
ich das selbst erst am montag erfahren
habt also war echt witzig
derad freut sich valentinstag mit jesus
gewalt ins netz zum geschenk nicht so
sehr muss man doch was überlege aber
naja ich habe jetzt ganz viele fragen
gesammelt und zwar ganz oft die frage
wie ich mich denn in der schwangerschaft
ernähre
als elvis der selber ich versuche mich
immer so gesund wie möglich zu ernähren
das heißt wir essen viel obst viel
gemüse wir ernähren uns ausgewogen und
das mache ich eben in der
schwangerschaft eigentlich genauso nur
dass ich jetzt noch mal darauf achte und
sagt okay heute die fünf portionen obst
und gemüse am tag die muss ich einhalten
und weil mir die hand oft zu schwer
fällt habe ich ja schon mal erzählt
mache ich gerne smoothies das ist auch
jetzt der fall also jetzt achte ich
wirklich drauf dass ich wirklich jeden
tag mindestens ein smoothie zu mir nehme
da hatte ich euch ja auch schon mal ein
rezept gemacht vor allem mit diesen
grünen smoothie aber bei uns gibt die
halt immer ganz verschieden also ich
versuche jeden tag irgendwas anderes und
probiert was anderes aus und auf der
ambiente habe ich da auch damals noch in
blender von kitchenaid entdeckt da kam
dann raus und den haben wir jetzt auch
da und den benutze ich da eben weil der
einfach alles richtig schön fein mixed
und eben ja das ganze halt viel
schmackhafter macht finde ich werde bei
einem sushi ist mir halt immer ganz
wichtig dass wirklich alles richtig
klein gehäckselt wird und dass man schön
trinken kann vor allem die sanierer hier
neben mir trinkt es auch immer ganz gern
aber eben ohne stückchen viele hatten
mich auch schon nach dem mixer gefragt
ich habe es leider bisher noch nicht
geschafft als ich habe noch viele videos
die ich noch schneiden und bearbeiten
muss wie zum beispiel auch mein messe
video von friedrichshafen von der cache
world und auch von dem smoothie mixa
also das mache ich jetzt alles demnächst
von dem gartenweg genau vom hochbett auf
unserer terrasse will ich noch was
drehen also es ist wirklich gerade
ziemlich viel arbeit was auf mich
zukommt der morath arbeitet halt im
moment auch zehn stunden
am tag bei der arbeit band kommt nach
hause und versucht mich noch zu
unterstützen und das fällt mir im moment
ziemlich schwer
vor allem weil ich halt auch die samira
habe es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich
jetzt das erste mal schwanger bin und
einfach nur zeit für mich hätte sondern
ich habe schon kind um das ich mich
kümmern muss oder darf der sack sagte
sicher so was schönes
und dann eben jetzt auch die
schwangerschaft und die videos es sich
halt ziemlich viel und ich versuche halt
auch im moment noch das video tempo
beizubehalten also mit mittwoch freitag
sonntag immer ein video
aber ihr müsst euch halt überlegen ist
schon ziemlich viel arbeit
ihr habt vielleicht auch gemerkt ich
versuche zwar immer kommentare e mails
und nachrichten zu beantworten
aber ich schaffe einfach nicht mehr so
viele wie jetzt vor fünf sechs monaten
weil es einfach da auch immer mehr
zunimmt
aktuell habe ich 240 tausend abonnenten
unglaublich ich habe katainen statistik
geguckt im november horns glaube ich 140
oder 170 und jetzt habe ich schon wieder
100.000 mehr als echt wahnsinn auf jeden
fall versuche ich so gut es geht das
tempo beizubehalten
durch moritz unterstützung natürlich
aber es ist schon ziemlich anstrengend
geworden muss ich schon sagen da kann
ich auch gleich auf die frage
zurückkommen was jetzt zum beispiel von
der ersten zur zweiten schwangerschaft
sich jetzt verändert hat es ist
natürlich so wenn man das erste mal
schwanger ist haben einfach die zeit
flüssig man kann sich schwangerschaft
total genießen auch wenn man es
vielleicht nicht macht samira als es mit
ihr schwanger war habe ich ja noch
studiert zwar alles im sitzen und es war
eigentlich alles ziemlich locker
ich warte hat auch fünf jahre jünger
muss man sagen also weiter ein und von
sich im wodka 22 als sie dann zur welt
kam und da war es schon einfacher 426
muss man sagen
also das ist schon auch ein unterschied
und von den monaten her war es ja genau
gleich sie kam im november und jetzt
habe ich ja entbindungstermin im oktober
also von der jahreszeit her liege ich
genau weiß nur dass es halt monat jetzt
früher kommt ja der sommer wird es
wahrscheinlich bisschen anstrengend aber
ansonst nicht alles okay ich hatte auch
von anfang an nicht so wirklich
beschwerden gott sei dank so wie auch
bei der sanierung also mir war zwar bei
der jetzigen schwangerschaft am anfang
ziemlich schlecht aber jetzt nicht so
schlecht dass ich mich übergeben müssen
oder so dass in andere frauen echt viel
viel schlimmer dran und ich finde es
immer so schlimm wenn ich das dann höher
und ich bin echt froh dass ich das nicht
hatte und mir das echt verschont blieb
im moment habe ich eigentlich ja also
jetzt durch viele stehen vor der kamera
muss ich sagen oder in der küche habe
ich halt schon beschwerden im rücken
also das ist schon heftig weil abends
ist dann halt echt so wenn ich mich dann
mal oft so versetzt dass ich dann fast
nicht mehr hochkommen
also da wirklich auch der schmerz
richtig stark wird aber ich denke da
kann man jetzt im moment einfach nichts
machen ich habe mich heute sogar zum
yoga angemeldet ich hoffe das hilft ein
bisschen
morad heute abend hab ich yoga du gehst
stehe ich mir das ist zeit für mich eine
geburtsvorbereitung sie mit anderen
frauen im schlater reden ja wie
geburtsvorbereitung ja ach was also lag
noch besser miraval bei der
geburtsvorbereitung wenn man auch zwei
oder drei termine mit partner und bei
der geburtsvorbereitung lernt man ja
auch so sachen wie atemtechniken und
massage oder keine ahnung mit a bisserl
vorbereitet wobei ich im endeffekt zahlt
muss die atemübung bringen einen während
der geburt nichts weil ganz ehrlich man
einfach froh wenn's kind irgendwann
draußen ist und ob man atmet und wie man
atmet ist in dem moment ehrlich sagt
richtig egal und ich glaube jede hebamme
dieselbe mein kind gekriegt hat versteht
es auch wirklich nicht immer auf wenn
ich so ganz junge hebamme hat sie selber
noch kein kind hatte erst mal in meine
lage und dann verstehst du dass ich
jetzt nicht atmen wie lothar keine
ahnung
er hatte sich dann aber diesmal machen
wir das nicht als ich mach' jetzt keine
geburtsvorbereitung aber ich werde zur
schwangerschaftsgymnastik gehen und zum
yoga das mache ich würde mich
eine hebamme aktuell habe ich noch keine
die haben mich beide 100 zurückgerufen
ich hoffe wirklich dass es noch klappt
also es stimmt wirklich ich bin mir lebe
hier auf dem land anscheinend denn da
stand drin auf dem land muss man sicher
nicht viel früher nie hebamme kümmern
denn es ist wirklich schwer einen zu
finden
also wenn ihr eine hebamme in einer
umgebung ist dann meldet euch bei mir
bitte ein rezept soll ich schreibe das
mache ich später
und ja also das mache ich noch dass ich
praktisch durch die hebamme vielleicht
noch paar übungen mitbekommen wie ich
mein rücken vielleicht entlassen kann so
die bag gebote muskulatur stärken und so
weiter also das ist denke ich ganz
wichtig aber ich finde jeder
erstgebärenden empfehle ich auf jeden
fall so ein geburtsvorbereitungskurs
schwangerschaftsgymnastik weil man
einfach fit bleibt und fit wird für die
für die geburt und jahres yoga probiere
ich heute aus und erzählt euch dann
einfach mal als nächste mal wie das war
dann war das nächste große thema
natürlich zuerst mal das geschlecht
natürlich aber das möchte ich heute echt
noch nicht verraten
also ich war als ich in der 16 woche
schwanger packe ich sage immer bücher so
wie es momentan so viel gemüse für mir
sicher dass es vielleicht könnte es
könnte ein trog olivera nein befragen
sie nicht denn so einfach nein wir
fragen sie nicht denn die zwischen
kleinen geheimnisse sommers fertig sein
bruder eine schwester oder ein heiß
jetzt lacht samira wilsberg was bruder
schwester mit dem boden der schwester
oder nice
eine schwester wünscht sie sich ja klar
als mädchen habe ich mir eine schwester
gesagt na ja auf jeden fall das möchte
ich euch nämlich mal demnächst ich werde
nächste woche ein video machen
da möchte ich nämlich zum
schwangerschafts kuchen beziehungsweise
cupcakes machen und da verrate ich euch
das bleibt noch gespannt denn es war
auch wirklich echt noch ziemlich früh
als der arztes festgestellt hat und ich
bin mir halt erstmal lieber auf nummer
juli war als nummer sicher gehen euch
das dann verrate ja die nächste frage
war was hast du bisher schon gekauft
also bisher noch bis gestern hatte ich
noch gar nichts gekauft denn das ding
ist auch ich habe ja auch schon eine
tochter
das heißt viele sachen kann ich halt
auch ein zweites mal benutzen gerade was
so klar bekleidung und so weiter angeht
ich habe auch ich mein samira hat er mit
nur röckchen und kleider an
ist es egal ob mädchen oder ein junge
wird aber auch jahreszeitlich passt ja
auch perfekt sein samira kam im november
und das jetzige kind kommt im oktober
das heißt von der jahreszeit mit bodies
stramplern überrollt und so weiter das
passt halt auf jeden fall von der größe
her also wenn jetzt das kind netz
irgendwie überdimensional groß wird uns
ungefähr so groß wird wie samira und vor
allem sind es sowieso jetzt nicht so die
leute die ständig etwas neues kaufen
müssen
aber darüber mache ich euch mal ein
anderes video denn wenn's ums kaufen
geht geht ja nicht nur ums thema
kleidung es geht auch ums thema möbel
oder um kinderwagen um keine ahnung was
deswegen mache ich da mal gesonderten
video drüber und erzählt euch das das
einzige was ich jetzt gestern leider
kaufen musste weil es einfach so süß war
das sind diese zwei schuhe weil ich
einfach echt vergessen habe wie klein
baby füße sind also ist es wirklich
moralisch doch der wahnsinn oder dass
die da rein oder dass die samira da mal
reingepasst hat ob die musik diesmal
vermeiden dann diese kleine mütze und da
passt kein kopf rein
ja und dieser kleine party
wir haben also ich habe im prinzip alles
noch da warte ich hole ich mir dann auch
second hand weil ich finde einfach so
hat man keine schadstoffe mit drin
man hält die textile kette am laufen und
ich habe zum glück ganz viele
freundinnen auch die schon ganz viele
kinder haben und ich da eben die
kleidung daneben von denen bekommen dann
geht es wieder weiter
als er sich immer so ein kreislauf und
das finde ich auch ganz gut wenn man das
unterstützt und nicht immer alles neu
kauft also auch gerade was die
gesundheit des kindes angeht dann ganz
gut das ist mir das jetzt zeigte aber
eben auch schon gezeigt und zwar habe
ich auch einige gefragt wie ich denn die
samira darauf vorbereitet habe also
samira wünscht sich schon seit über zwei
jahren ein geschwisterchen und liegt uns
da auch ständig in den ohren letztes
jahr zuständig sagt mama wenn das baby
in den brauch rauskommt und ich hab ja
noch gar kein baby im bauch und so kam
eigentlich auch der wunsch bei uns als
er bei murat und bei mir das jetzt noch
mal nachwuchs kriegen und deswegen war
das halt auch geplant also dass er drei
wünsche frei außerdem hier mache ich
aber nicht also früher wollte ich mal 42
mädchen und zwei jungs jetzt habe ich
die samira und jetzt betritt ist denke
ich auch mal weniger geld dann richtig
ich finde ich würde auch fünf oder sechs
kinder machen aber man muss halt auch
die zeit für die kinder haben vor allem
muss das geld haben und es bringt ja nix
kinder auf die welt zu setzen sich nicht
drum zu kümmern und nicht um reines
kabarett aus meinem körper ist wie viel
muss auch die zeit habe und ja ich habe
zurzeit mit sandra genossen sie wird
jetzt im november fünf ich hätte
vielleicht schon letztes jahr ein kind
mir gewünscht aber beruflich ging es
halt einfach nicht deswegen ist das
jetzt okay aber ich möchte immer die
zeit genießen und dann halt das nächste
auf jeden fall haben wir die samira halt
eigentlich gar nicht darauf vorbereiten
müssen sie hat sich das selber schon
gewünscht zum glück und als beim
wirklich soweit war und ich festgestellt
habe dass ich schwanger bin
hab ich sie dann auch erzählt und hast
ja auch sehr gefreut so vieles auf
einmal und ich habe mir dann eine app
heruntergeladen und zwar hat die mir
eine freundin empfohlen die heißt
pregnancy die ich aber anfangen
kostenlos danach kann man sie kaufen
wenn man auch die extras will ich habe
sie dafür knapp drei euro fünfzig oder
so runtergeladen und es ist ganz toll
ich zeig euch auch gleich in nahaufnahme
und zwar kanada eingeben war neben der
entbindungstermin tisch und dann
rechnete die app eben aus wie lange du
jetzt schon schwanger bist also bei mir
steht heute drin
hallo sunny season 20 wochen und 2 tage
schwanger
dann steht drin noch 19 wochen und fünf
tage bis zur geburt es steht jeden tag
im block bericht drin gut ab und zu
stehen auch echt schwachsinnige sachen
drin wie wie bringe ich meiner freundin
bei oder stand echtes der komische
sachen muss ich schon sagen dann sind
halt immer bilder mit drin was halt für
uns für die samira ganz toll ist denn
die samira sie praktisch wie das baby
hat mit wächst und sie sagte nur mama
jeden morgen und jeden abend sagt
zimmermann lasst uns mal gucken wie
unser baby gewachsen ist wie groß es
schon ist und also so nimmt die das
praktisch mit und da finde ich halt so
ein smartphone oder ein tablet hat echt
günstig weil sie deshalb mit verfolgen
kann wenn ich jetzt nur ihr mein bauch
zeigt wo man eigentlich die ersten drei
monaten noch nichts gesehen hat dann
kann sie sich das nicht vorstellen und
so ganze halt immer sehen wie das baby
leyen mit wächst und wie dann die
fingernägel wachsen
dieses baby entsteht
die voll interessiert war na ja also das
ist die eine möglichkeit und ansonsten
reden wir halt viel drüber und so freut
sich schon drauf und wenn wir auch
einkaufen sind sagt sie was möchtest du
ein eis mitnehmen fürs baby aber um sie
hat erzählt dass babys nicht da sondern
kommt erst noch
und ganz ganz wichtig weil ich meinen
neid und eifersucht könne immer
auftreten
und ich möchte nicht dass das passiert
bzw möchte halt so eingrenzen will dass
er ein grenzen wie es hat nur möglich
ist und eine freundin von mir hat mal
den tipp gegeben
machst du einfach so sagt das baby
bringt aus dem krankenhaus und geschenk
mit und so haben wir das auch gemacht
und die samira darf sich nämlich ein
geschenk wünschen
was soll s geschickt warum das debüt
bringen und das baby bringt dir was mit
aus dem krankenhaus passt was soll's
tier mitbringen
nein nein das baby sollte aus mitbringen
wenn es nach hause kommt was hast du dir
gewünscht
du kannst ja auch noch mal überlegen sie
wünscht sich ein prinzessinnenkleid und
es wünscht sich halt vom baby- und das
baby bringt ihr dann mit den dann hat
die sanierer eben auch was voran find
ich's halt wichtig wenn das kind dann
wirklich da ist und man zum beispiel
dann auch besuch bekommt ich mein ist
dreht sich halt einiges ums baby und das
hier natürlich auch so sein aber ich bin
zeit vor allem wichtig wenn sich dann
später alles hat ums baby spät dass man
das große kind natürlich nicht vergisst
und ich mache zum beispiel auch so wenig
zu baby besucht und irgendwie ein
größeres geschwisterchen da ich dann
bringe ich dem auch meistens was mit bzw
über mich als erstes kind und dann halt
ums baby also das sind immer alle direkt
aufs baby stürme und die große schwester
oder der große bruder dann
vernachlässigt werde
man sollte also soweit ich es versuchen
ich möchte dass amira dann auch
verantwortung übergeben und hat sagen
komm jetzt wickeln wir zusammen das baby
und so weiter
aber bis dahin haben wir noch zeit also
ja wir bereiten sie jetzt so vor dass
man eben darüber reden und eben mit
dieser app also das finde ich ganz
praktisch was das thema gewichtszunahme
und so weiter betrifft war
samira so da habe ich damals als ich
kann es offen ehrlich sage ich stehe zu
meinem gewicht ist alles okay alles im
grünen bereich habe ich besser mira ich
glaube mit 58 kilo gestartet und habe am
ende
sage und schreibe 83 kilo gewogen
wie viele stift 25 kilo
er schaut ziemlich viel aber das meiste
davon habe ich echt am ende zugenommen
und dieses mal ich habe jetzt ein
startgewicht von 60 kilo ich war fast
wieder bei meinem 58 wobei es ja was
wenig als 60 bahnstadt gewicht und bei
eigener und besser mehr also ich hab
erst ab der achtzehnter woche zugenommen
also kurz vor der halbzeit dieses mal
habe ich schon früher zugenommen soll
auch ein zweiter kind ganz normal sein
hat sie auch viel schneller gesehen also
man hat ja schon im dritten monat oder
ja eigentlich schon ziemlich früh bei
mir so eine werbung gesehen und jetzt
bin ich ja card anfang sechster monaten
habe ich auch schon gebaut
zeig ich euch auch gleich und jetzt habe
ich glaube ich schon
keine ahnung fünf oder sechs kilo
zugenommen ich habe ehrlich habe daheim
gerade keine waage und kann mich immer
nur beim frauenarzt wege und der wiegt
römischer weise immer bisschen mehr als
jetzt ich bei meiner mama weg aber egal
naja es auf jeden fall hält sich das
auch in grenzen
und ja wir haben es wieder runter
gekriegt ich hatte halt gestellt und ich
weiß es ging allein wieder weg also groß
sportlich bin ich ja nett ist ihr aber
ich versuche dieses mal danach sport zu
machen weil ich merke schon auch
geradeaus rückenprobleme und so angeht
kann man dem hat vorbeugen wenn man sich
bis sportlich betätigt und bauch und
rückenmuskulatur stärkt da werde ich ein
paar workouts von der lieben an helfern
bodykits machen kann ich mich auch zu
dem programm angemeldet
wenn du das video sich also dein workout
programm ist wirklich toll aber im
moment nämlich mehr zu als ab also das
geht ja ein kleiner witz also also nach
der schwangerschaft mache ich dann deine
pause gehts gewicht wieder runter und
nicht hoch im moment wirkt sich halt
alles aber naja ich hab mich die ganze
zeit was ich noch vergessen habe zu
erwähnen übrigens habe ich immer meine
wasserflasche auf meinem schoß weil ich
muss mich echt wegen hin zum trinken als
ich versuche immer so drei flaschen am
tag zu trinken meistens mache ich mir da
noch so mit strom schreibe mit
oder einfach geschickter mintzel oder
etwas wie heißt dass zitronenmelisse
schmeckt auch ganz gut finden habe ich
deswegen auch ein schuss als wunder
natürlich muss man eine schwangerschaft
auch gewisse regeln einhalten
das war gut zu mir die stadt beleidigt
was jetzt die ernährung angeht man muss
natürlich auch rohes ei verzichten auf
rohen fisch und rohes fleisch
da habe ich auch einige gefragt und es
schwer fällt natürlich fällt es mir
nicht schwer weil das ist ja nur für
eine gewisse zeit also sind 40 wochen
danach könnt ihr wieder alles essen und
trinken was ihr wollt natürlich nur
bedingt wenn man jetzt auch noch stillt
und ich habe im moment zum beispiel
total gelüste auf tiramisu mit roma aber
ich es natürlich nett weil mir einfach
das wohl des kindes vorgeht und viel
wichtiger ist und ansonsten drohen rohen
fisch essig ähnelt rohes fleisch auch
nicht vor kurzem habe ich ein instagram
post gemacht das war ganz wichtig also
ein stück gegessen habe nicht gebraten
und habe geschrieben rotes tuch
aber im prinzip ist das motto krieg roth
es wird ja vorher gebrühtem eines logic
experte murat und ja dann halte ich mich
natürlich an alles und für fällt mir
nicht schwer muss ich sage ja im moment
habe ich die sind mein hunger als sonst
aber ich glaub das ist normal und
deshalb viele kleine portionen und dafür
hat mehrere portionen am tag
september also etwa fünf wochen vor
geburt findet ihr in wien noch die kate
messestadt auf die wir gehen möchte und
wenn alles so läuft wie bisher mit
meiner schwangerschaft es geht mir gut
ich kann halt nur nicht lang stehen also
vor kurzem war die messe in
friedrichshafen und ich war drei tage
lang wirklich sehr lange immer gestanden
und danach ging es noch ein paar tage
netze rot weil es einfach total in dem
im rücken hatte und wir werden auf jeden
fall mit hingehen natürlich wenn alles
gut läuft denn da
hinfliegen weil beim auto ist mir das zu
lang die zehn stunden fahrt aber das ist
ja dann im flugzeug sind es knapp mehr
als eine stunde
und da freue ich mich echt schon drauf
und ich habe mir auch schon gesagt dass
sich die stadt so toll findet und so
aufregend finde ich warte halt noch nie
und sogar schon jemand über e-mail
gemeldet ich glaube katharina weiß du
und sie möchte bei uns einen reiseführer
machen morath das habe ich dir noch gar
nicht erzählt lässt sich als reiseführer
verfügung gestellt die messe wird
natürlich etwas anders ablaufen als
jetzt in friedrichshafen oder hamburg
ich werde halt entstehen und stunden
lang kochen und backen
das wird diesmal der murat machen als
wir um abgemacht dass er dies dann
übernimmt weil er sich ja auch aus kennt
mittlerweile und da muss schon vorher
einfach paar videos gucke und auto
weiter wie das alles geht oder wenn
etwas macht eine einfachste fall zu
ducati butter schmelzen oder einfach
smoothies machen kann schon machen und
ich komme auf jeden fall mit dazu eben
solange alles gut läuft und wer dann
auch fotos usw
mit euch machen um mich mit euch
unterhalten also da freue ich mich echt
und drauf ich stelle mich halt nur nett
stunde lang hin aber ich glaube das ist
normal und kann jeder nachvollziehen
ein weiteres projekt fragen mich auf
viele immer noch ein backbuch ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen im moment ist es
einfach bis zu viel auch und es kommt
gerade echt nett vorwärts vor allem ich
hab halt gesagt ich möchte keinen verlag
der mir alles abnimmt weil ich will
selber mein buch schreibe ich will
keinen ghostwriter der dann für mich
meine texte schreibt meine rezepte
schreibt ich will halt alles selber
machen das sind alles meine rezepte
meine bilder ich werde mich dann mit
unserem freund marius hinstellen und die
fotos machen das sind ja keine
gestellten bilder wo irgend ein hähnchen
angepinselt wird sondern es wird dann
wirklich gebacken nach rezept eventuell
mit video so haben wir es uns
vorgestellt und dann ebenso das buch
gemacht aber das ist mir einfach im
moment zu anstrengend und ich will halt
net einfach ein buch machen damit
gemacht ist und auf dem markt kommt
sondern es soll ja wirklich mein buch
dann werden und ich bin als ich weiß ob
es wissen von sternzeichen jungfrau
ziemlich perfektionistisch von daher
muss es halt auch echt perfekt werden
und ich denke mir lieber wartet damit
dann noch und es langsam angehen ohne
stress ohne dass ich irgendwann im
burnout lande und dann halt weshalb auch
ein schönes buch was ich ganz schön 5 in
der schwangerschaft das alte samira auch
gemacht
ich habe mir ab und zu notizen gemacht
also so wie es mir geht und was sich so
verändert
auch was die gefühle angeht und kann das
hat jetzt etwas besser mir
aufgeschrieben habe ab und zu mal
durchlesen und sehe dann hat auch die
veränderungen jetzt außerdem
veränderungen die mutterpass stehen und
da hat mir jetzt auf der messe in
friedrichshafen jemand das buch
mitgebracht und zwar ist es so ein buch
das die mama dann in der schwangerschaft
begleitet und einfach so die ersten paar
jahre vom kind und da trage ich jetzt
demnächst alles mal ein und schreibt es
hat alles nieder weil ich dann auch ganz
süß finde wenn später dann das kind
größer wird und sich das einfach durch
lesen kann
und ja da stehen halt doch gefühle von
der mama drin oder einfach so privates
sachen das ganze erinnert aber ich
find's schön vor allem für die mama
selber auch abgeworfen dass ein floß
ausgebildet worden und da habe ich jetzt
hat auch meine bilder drin meine
ultraschallbilder und die 3d bilder vom
baby das finde ich ja ganz schön wenn
man das so bisserl sich notiert und
einfach seine gedanken nieder schreibt
dass ich ganz schön was sich übrigens
vergessen habe ihn der ebwo ich vorhin
gesagt haben dieser pregnancy ob die
kann man sich auch als papa
herunterladen das hast du gar nicht
gemacht morath und zwar kein statist
auch runterladen als papa oder als
freundinnen als schwester und dann
kannst du praktisch ein geben ich bin
der papa und dann steht da alles für den
papa halt geschrieben wie er seine seine
partnerin unterstützen kann wir sehr gut
vorbereiten kann und so weiter also das
finde ich echt schön
diese eltern erstmal kein man gestehen
dass ich eine app vom amerikanischen
markt wollte ich noch dazu sagen ja aber
ich bin grad als papa eines des ersten
kindes kann man sich sowas gut runter
leute waren da steht alles drin
bye bye samira hatte ich damals ein buch
und habe das gelesen das muss jetzt noch
mal lesen
das hat mir damals auch sehr geholfen
vor allem mit den veränderungen im
körper zu recht zu kommen und mich
einfach darauf vorzubereiten
denn ich glaube für eine frau ist
einfach halt auch ingrid ganz
umständlich so war es umstellt
eine umstellung wenn man halt wenn sich
der körper so rasch auch verändert als
du nimmst immer innerhalb von wenigen
wochen und monaten so viel zu es wird
alles anstrengender und du fragst dich
natürlich geht es danach wieder weg und
asthma hat halt ja so probleme halt mich
und ich finde da kann man sich immer gut
drauf vorbereitet
timo stuhl hat weder weltkriege und dann
steht hat noch so manila der kammer hat
er dann sagt hallo ich sehe den bauch
also das geht wohl gabel verfolgt zumal
es sich auch im bauch an gegessen hat
und der nach der schwangerschaft nicht
weggeht
ach ja nächste woche und zwar nächste
woche ich hatte nämlich vor kurzem
besuch von dem galileo team von
prosieben und nächste woche am
donnerstag als am 11
juni kommt dieser beitrag online es ist
echt ein richtig schöner beitrag
geworden glaube ich bin selbst auch
nicht gesehen als ich sitze auch vom
fernsehen und gucke mir das dann zum
ersten mal selber an
und was ganz besonderes und richtig
aufregend das für mich wir werden an
diesem tag werde ich nochmal besucher
kriegen von galileo team und ich werde
nach der ausstrahlung als ich glaube
aleo geht immer so eine stunde von 19
uhr bis knapp 20 uhr 2015 und danach
gibt es im anschluss direkt ein live
event das heißt ich werde vor der kamera
live backen
vielleicht auch was kochen
wirken häuser nur artig mit dabei und da
werden wir eine dreiviertelstunde als 45
minuten wirklich live backen und ihr
könnt uns dabei zugucken und das galileo
team wird dann vorher schon dir das
rezept veröffentlichen die zutaten dann
könnt ihr theoretisch wenn ihr wollt
parallel auch mit backen also das ist ja
ich bin ich schon aufgeregt weil ich war
noch nie live irgendwo außerhalb auf
messen
nächste woche donnerstag alle müsste
alle kosten gucken also diese schätzen
ein pflichttermin eine stunde
das ist echt war die jugend galileo und
dann ist ein abgang in unserem wissen
nicht einmal ob salat das moderierte
aber elfer krimi auf jeden fall ist echt
cool als ich freue mich da richtig offen
bin auch ich schon aufgeregt weil hallo
live hallo kann so viel schief gehen
müssen nur samira ja dass ich ein
bisschen spät
ich glaube dass ich so eigentlich die
meisten fragen beantwortet habe wenn
euch noch fragen einfallen und ihr gerne
noch ein update sehen möchte
dann schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare ich werde auf jeden fall wie
gesagt noch eins machen über einkaufen
also einkaufen für die schwangerschaft
wenn ihr gerne möchte dass ich zum
beispiel mehrere rezeptideen für baby
shower party mache oder schwangerschafts
torten kuchen usw
dann lasst mich das auch wissen ich bin
zur baby show partys ganz süß bei
sanierer hatte ich keine daten im
internet zu im trend und nehmen wie hat
sich da keine schon gekümmert
jetzt habe ich das meiner freundin nadja
als aufgabe gegeben sagt donath er die
beste freundin muss das plane also muss
sieht es für mich brauchen euch
wahrscheinlich werde ich selbst auch für
mich packen
eine coole sau mama mama bestimmt da
gibt es eine seite da wurde ich vor
kurzem kontaktiert
der punkt de an mehr heißt ja man auf
türkisch als mama an den punkt de das
ist eine seite und bei facebook bin ich
noch bei auf der seite also habe ich
gefällt mir gedrückt bei von mutter zu
mutter da kommen ab und zu mal coole
beiträge und da tauschen sich auch
mittag gegenseitig aus auch anonym weil
manchmal will merr net dass jemand weiß
weitere stellen hat und so weiter
ja auf jeden fall so videos sind für
mich ziemlich komisch man normalerweise
steht da und gucken oder bars und
winslet gewohnt einfach so vor der
kamera zu stehen irgendwie ja demnächst
fertig übrigens amiras zimmer
verschönern denn wir haben ihre wände
nicht gestrichen als es sich praktisch
bei ihre möbel sind weiß und ich habe
mir jetzt ein konzept gemacht wie ich
ihr zimmer verschönere und ich werde
damit überraschen
samira wirklich bald ein zimmer schön
gemacht ja genau das problem ist dass
krieg augen schnupfen
das problem ist unsere wohnung ist nicht
klein also werden 110 quadratmeter etwa
wohnfläche das problem ist halt blöd
geschnitten wir haben hatten offenen
eine offene wohn ess küche also den
bereich und haben ein schlafzimmer haben
ein kinderzimmer eine abstellkammer es
da verstehe ich immer alles und das
war's dann beschreibt ziemlich viel
fluor da das heißt also ich bin jetzt
nicht so dass ich sage ein kind braucht
ein eigenes zimmer ich hatte kein zimmer
bis ich 16 war
das ist das problem aber ich finds halt
einfach es wird es ziemlich eng
und ja ich denke irgendwann wir wollen
ja auch mal irgendwann was eigenes das
ist glaube ich das ziel formulierte
gleich sagt leicht ich sag jetzt tschüss
dass wir gleich schwimmen gehen
ja ich denke das war es soweit und fragt
mich einfach irgendwelche sachen wenn
ihr was wissen will schreibt in die
kommentare rein ich werde chef instagram
natürlich auch im aufnahme laufen halten
da heißt es trocken welt der mode heißt
es mit der post ja auch immer mal wieder
sachen vor allem auch fotos von sich und
darf mit geben da schützt eine schlimme
sachen holen und wir gehen gleich
schwimmen
fragen können auch gerne denn murat
fragen wie erst während der
schwangerschaft fühlt also während
meiner schwangerschaft
nein du gehst einfach deinen schwimmen
zu mir du gehst jetzt deine seine stimme
den schwimmanzug holen und wir gehen
jetzt also wir sehen uns das nächste mal
ein bisschen schnell wieder bei gelb